we're facing a lot of problems as a
nation record high inflation Rising
crime food shortages Chinese spy planes
and the prospect of World War III but
one issue rises above all those threats
and President Biden addressed it last
night during the State of the Union I
speak of course about hotel resort fees
my Administration is also taking on junk
fees those hidden surcharges too many
companies use to make you pay more we're
going to ban surprise Resort fees that
hotels charge an honor Bill those fees
can cost up to ninety dollars a night in
hotels that aren't even Resorts people
can't afford eggs the cost of eggs Rose
60 last year Joe Biden hasn't fixed any
of the things he said he'd fix in almost
every single case he's made those
problems worse but hey he says he's
going to try really hard to reduce
Resort fees